The whole fabric of America is bloody to its
very core.
And there’s no quicker way to find out someone
shares your bloodlust than when the subject
of serial killers comes up.
Think about the recent renaissance of true
crime shows.
Look at what some of the top rated podcasts
are.
People cannot get enough murder in their recreational
unwinding time.
It’s a way of living vicariously, and maybe
it’s healthy overall, but it’s more than
a little dark.
Serial killers and their tales of adventure
that captivated the public really seemed to
hit a stride in the 1960s and thereafter.
The Zodiac Killer, Son of Sam, Ed Gein, and
John Wayne Gacy kept people glued to their
newspapers and news broadcasts to see what
awful, mesmerizing things they had done.
The cities and towns where these killers operated
stayed gripped in fear during their unpredictable
and sporadic reigns of terror, and that was
just as true in the upstate New York town
of Rochester in the early 1970s.
There, between 1971 and 1973, someone was
kidnapping children and murdering them.
But that’s just the beginning of the weirdness
surrounding these cases.
Here, we take a look at the Alphabet Murders.
The First Murder
In the mid-afternoon of November 16, 1971,
10-year-old Carmen Colon was running errands
before returning back to her home in Rochester.
She made a stop at a pharmacy to pick up a
prescription for her grandmother, and while
being informed that the medication was not
yet ready to be picked up, became noticeably
distracted and upset.
She told the owner of the pharmacy that she
“had to go”, and got into a car parked
nearby.
Three hours later, she was reported missing
to the Rochester Police Department.
In those few hours between her leaving the
pharmacy and becoming an official missing
person, she was observed on a local interstate,
half naked and flailing her arms for help.
A vehicle identified as a dark Ford Pinto
was backing up frantically trying to run her
down, and eventually an individual overpowered
her and threw her back into the car.
About thirty-eight motorists on the highway
witnessed the act, though not one soul attempted
to intervene in the apparent abduction.
None of the drivers who saw what happened
even thought to call it in until three days
later.
Unfortunately, by that time, it was too late.
On November 18, two teenagers came across
the body of Carmen Colon, nearly twelve miles
from where she was seen struggling on the
interstate.
Some of her clothing was in fact found near
that very highway.
She had been raped, her skull had been fractured,
and she had been strangled to death.
Local newspapers soon offered up a meager
reward for whoever could offer information
leading to an arrest, and some billboards
were later erected asking for clues.
The potential suspects that would crop up
after the first murder and later would only
add more perplexing questions to the cases.
The First Suspect
Miguel Colon was Carmen Colon’s uncle, and
after her parents split up he became even
closer to Carmen and her mother.
When she would take her usual walks to the
pharmacy, she was usually accompanied by her
grandfather, Felix, but on the day of her
disappearance she somehow persuaded him to
let her travel alone.
This was the day that she got into a strange
car.
Later on the highway, she was fleeing from
what was presumably the same car, a dark Ford
Pinto hatchback.
Just before Carmen Colon went missing, her
uncle Miguel took possession of a car that
eerily matched the car from the highway incident.
When authorities learned of this, they went
to Miguel’s home to search the vehicle.
During the investigation, they took note of
the car having recently been profusely cleaned,
especially the trunk, which had been gone
over in detail with a rather strong cleaning
product.
If you’ve paid attention to anyone’s car
trunk ever, you’ll know that this is a pretty
rare occurrence.
Investigators asked the dealership if that
was a common practice, since it was a relatively
new purchase on Miguel’s behalf.
The dealers stated that they had not conducted
such a cleaning.
More creepily, a doll of Carmen’s was found
in the car, which he explained off by saying
he was a family member, and that wasn’t
very strange at all.
What was strange, however, was Miguel’s
sudden panic two days after Carmen’s death,
in which he allegedly told a friend he had
to flee the country because he had “done
something wrong in Rochester”, and indeed
he did take off to Puerto Rico very soon after.
You haven’t heard the last of Miguel Colon.
The Second Murder
On an early April afternoon in 1972, more
than a year after Carmen Colon’s murder,
11-year-old Wanda Walkowicz was heading to
her home after an errand, much like Carmen
had been.
In her hometown of Rochester, just like Carmen.
She was getting groceries, and headed back
down the road towards her house.
It was 5:15 pm.
Joyce, Wanda’s mother, reported her missing
around 8 pm.
A slew of detectives canvassed an enormous
area of land near her home.
They scoured the area around the grocery store
they knew she had been at before her disappearance,
and they searched near the local river where
they knew she would sometimes play.
Rescue teams heard a few straggling reports
of Wanda, grocery bags in hand, resting against
a fence to keep herself from dropping the
bags, as a dark brown vehicle approached her.
10 am the next morning, a policeman found
her body at the base of a hill.
It had been apparently thrown from a moving
car, and rolled down to the ground below.
She had been sexually assaulted and choked
to death, much like Carmen the previous year.
She had fought her attacker, which was clear
from the defensive wounds.
Oddly, she had a noticeable amount of white
cat hair on her body, even though her family
owned no such animals.
During the autopsy, custard was discovered
among her stomach contents, something her
family swore she would not have eaten at home
or school.
So was her killer feeding her before taking
on his nefarious task?
Hotlines were set up, much larger rewards
of up to $10,000 were offered, and tips rolled
in from the public.
One tip came from someone who said they saw
Wanda speaking with the driver of that brown
car from the passenger side window just before
she went missing.
Another tip said they saw a man forcing a
girl matching Wanda’s looks into a light-colored
Dodge Dart-type automobile.
Fliers were plastered all over the surrounding
neighborhoods in the hopes that any shred
of evidence would point investigators in the
right direction.
The already-apparent surface similarities
between Carmen and Wanda’s cases were almost
immediately dismissed by the local police
department.
More suspects, more tips, and even more questions
ensued.
The Third Victim
Michelle Maenza was returning home from school
on November 26, 1973, just about seven months
after the murder of Wanda Walkowicz.
The eleven-year-old stopped at a Rochester
department store on the way back, attempting
to fetch a purse her mother had left there
earlier.
Her uncle passed her at some point, offering
to give her a ride, but Michelle opted to
go it alone.
Witnesses reported that soon after, she was
seen entering a tan or beige vehicle.
This was not her uncle’s car.
Her mother reported her missing that evening.
Around 4:30 pm, a girl who matched Maenza’s
features was seen eating at a fast food restaurant
with a man described as a Caucasian between
the ages of 25 and 35, and roughly 6 foot,
165 lbs.
A person traveling down a nearby road around
5:30 pm that day said they saw the same beige
or tan color of vehicle as earlier in the
afternoon, but with a flat tire.
The motorist also apparently saw a girl that
looked very much like Michelle, and noticed
she was in a fair amount of distress.
She was being held by the wrist by the driver
outside of the car, and when the approaching
witness tried to stop and check on the girl,
he was met with a glare by the suspect.
The kidnapper tried to hide the girl behind
him and also attempted to keep his license
plate out of sight.
He put off a menacing enough vibe that the
would-be helper drove off.
Two days later, on November 28th, Michelle
Maenza’s body was found in a ditch roughly
15 miles from her home.
Just like the first two victims, she had been
sexually assaulted and then strangled with
some kind of rope or cord.
And just like Wanda Walkowicz, she had numerous
strands of white cat hair on her.
Some small samples of prints and semen were
able to be recovered, and upon autopsy, her
stomach contents included traces of hamburger,
backing up the story of her being last seen
at a fast food restaurant.
A composite sketch of the man who was seen
with her was circulated but, like most of
the tiny nuggets of possible leads that crept
up throughout the case, real concrete information
was not to be had.
Eerie Similarities
So why were these dubbed the “Alphabet Murders”?
Well, you may have noticed that all three
victims had first and last names that started
with the same letter.
As time has gone on, experts think that the
likelihood that this was intentional is very
low.
But even if the killer had chosen his victims
on this basis, that’s not even the strangest
of the similarities in the crimes.
There’s the final resting place of each
body.
All three children were from Rochester, but
when their bodies were discovered, it was
in a different town, and each town corresponded
to their names.
Carmen Colon’s body was found in the town
of Churchville, Wanda Walkowicz was 7 miles
away from Rochester in the village of Webster,
and Michelle Maenza was found in Macedon.
While you could argue that the names were
coincidences, it’s hard to argue that the
killer didn’t somehow plan to dump each
victim in a place that matched their name
lettering.
There’s the obvious fact that each of the
victims was a pre-teen girl.
They all three disappeared during rainy days,
were of a short height, and were all seen
as loner types, without many close friends.
The positioning of each body when they were
found seemed to point to them all being thrown
from a vehicle.
Each girl was brought up in a poor Catholic
family and had histories with being bullied
and having issues with academic performance
in school, which gave investigators some inkling
that the murderer may have had a background
in social services, and thus had access to
knowing these very specific details about
the girls.
More Suspects, Fewer Answers
Miguel Colon, as we mentioned, spirited away
to Puerto Rico four short days after his niece
was killed.
In March of 1972, investigators made their
way down there to begin asking him questions
about her disappearance and murder.
The fact that he had a car that resembled
the one seen during the time of Carmen’s
kidnapping, and the suspicious extent to which
the vehicle had been cleaned gave them plenty
of reasonable doubt.
However, down in Puerto Rico, newspapers caught
wind of the authorities’ desire to interview
him and published articles that Miguel saw,
causing him to flee.
He did return later in March, and was extradited
back to New York state.
During questioning, Miguel was not able to
provide a sufficient excuse for where he was
during Carmen’s disappearance, and had no
other people that could back him up regarding
his location that day.
Despite strong suspicion that they had their
guy, in the end there was no physical evidence
that could definitively link him or his car
to the crimes.
In 1991, twenty years after his niece Carmen
was killed, Miguel took his own life after
being involved in a dispute at home where
he shot his brother and his wife.
The good samaritan who tried to approach the
individual who had captured Michelle Maenza
was a bit of help.
Even though the kidnapper tried to block him
from seeing his license plate, that person
was able to read off a partial plate to the
authorities.
As luck would have it, he ran across the same
car several days later, and was able to provide
the full plate number.
This led police to a man living with his family
in Lyons, New York, just over 40 miles from
Rochester.
This new suspect had a beige-colored sedan,
a strong resemblance to witness sketches,
and had been in trouble with the law for petty
crimes for quite a while.
His alibi to the police was that he had been
out looking for work that entire day.
Upon further investigation and perusing of
phone records, it seemed that his alibi was
airtight.
He even passed a polygraph.
The suspect never had his name released, and
even though he might have been the closest
the police got to a real lead, it never panned
out.
Dennis Termini was another potential lead
in the Alphabet Murders.
A local firefighter in the Rochester area,
Termini was also known locally as the “Garage
Rapist”, and had raped at least fourteen
females between the years of 1971 and 1973,
which are the years that the Alphabet Murders
occurred.
Termini owned a beige-colored car, which was
the color vehicle that had been seen at more
than one of the abductions.
He also resided on a street very close to
the area where witnesses last reported seeing
Michelle Maenza.
Michelle Maenza was thought to be the last
victim of the “Alphabet Murders”, but
five weeks after her death, Dennis Termini
tried to pull a gun on a teenage girl with
the intent of abducting her.
She started screaming, which led him to flee
the scene, but he obviously didn’t learn
his lesson and tried again soon after to kidnap
another girl.
Police were made aware, and started after
him.
Termini was not going to be captured alive,
and so he shot himself in the head.
Years later, forensic studies were conducted
with Termini’s exhumed corpse.
They compared DNA from his body to semen samples
that were saved from Wanda Walkowicz, the
second Alphabet victim.
Nothing matched.
Unfortunately, no evidence was available from
Michelle Maenza’s body, the one victim they
had him most closely tied to.
His car, however, had all sorts of white car
hair on the surfaces within.
White cat hair was found on two of the Alphabet
victims.
Kenneth Bianchi drew police interest because
he lived and worked near the first two murder
locations.
He held jobs as an ice cream man, a security
guard, and an ambulance driver, which made
investigators think he wore many uniforms
that would make children approach him and
trust him.
He too had a car that matched the description
passed around as being near the scenes of
the Alphabet abductions.
Biancha moved to California in 1976, three
years after the last killing.
He, along with his cousin, became a serial
killer on the west coast, becoming the Hillside
Strangler.
Between 1977 and 1978, they murdered ten females
between the ages of 12 and 28, though Biancha
strongly denies having anything to do with
the Alphabet murders.
Yet another suspect was Joseph Naso, who did
his own series of killings in California between
1977 and 1994.
His victims were mostly believed to be prostitutes,
but one interesting detail that came up was
that all the females he killed had first and
last names that began with the same letter,
just like the Alphabet murders.
Naso was also a Rochester, New York native,
and lived there in the early 1970s.
In fact, he often traveled back and forth
between New York and California, and this
wasn’t lost on investigators.
The same samples that were tested from Wanda
Walkowicz’s body against Dennis Termini
were tested against Naso’s DNA, and did
not match.
Naso was convicted of his own California Alphabet
murders, however, and was sentenced to death
in 2013.
When police searched his house more thoroughly,
they found an absolutely insane journal where
Naso kept the details of his murders.
An Eternal Mystery
Obviously, the Alphabet Murders remain unsolved
to this day.
Little pieces of evidence have pointed to
many potential suspects, but none of it has
been indisputable enough to land a conviction.
It’s not even truly known if all three murders
are definitely connected.
Tips rolled in from the public, and new suspects
had a brief light shining on them, but then
something wouldn’t connect.
A polygraph would pass, or an alibi would
line up.
Did Joseph Naso merely move to California
and continue killing there, retaining the
alphabet method?
Was it someone else entirely, and they just
moved somewhere else and killed there?
Did they feel like the law was closing in
after the third murder, and they somehow quelled
the urge to kill again?
There are so many questions and zero sense
of closure from the families.
Even the experts have a hard time drawing
conclusions.
One such expert was Robert Ressler, who actually
came up with the term “serial killer”
and who spent decades profiling them and trying
to get inside their heads.
Ressler worked at the FBI, in the Behavioral
Studies Unit, where he got to examine the
actions and thoughts of some of the most horrid
people that ever lived.
Ressler actually did not believe the same
person conducted all three killings.
When he drew up profiles of the killers, he
believed that Carmen’s killing showed a
much higher level of anger and aggression.
She also had not received food before her
death, like the other two girls seemingly
did.
Finally, the killer choked her with his hands,
whereas Wanda and Michelle had ligatures used
on them.
The experts also seemed to believe that the
matching first and last initials of each victim
was purely coincidence.
They believed that level of thought required
organizational skill that the killer simply
did not have.
The murders, the brutal dumping of the bodies,
and even the kidnappings themselves had no
methodical orchestration to them, Ressler’s
team concluded.
Is it possible that the killer’s trial run
with Carmen didn’t go according to plan,
and that he got better at his work with the
next two?
Of course, but we can’t say.
Three Epilogues
The New York State Police, City of Rochester
police, and two neighboring county departments
all still have open cases for the girls who
were killed.
The departments still work closely together
and meet to discuss new details when they
come up.
New technology being much more advanced than
what was at the police’s disposal in the
1970s, they are now able to test genetics
and swab for DNA to create new suspects or
eliminate past ones.
Databases are available to instantly access
information from decades ago.
The original detectives meet with the new
guard to pick each others’ brains and share
leads.
They all share the same sense of wanting to
honor the memories of the girls and help the
families close a door that’s been maddeningly
left open for so long.
Carmen Colon, Wanda Walkowicz, and Michelle
Maena all share the same cemetery in Rochester
as their final resting place.